8月11本投稿中登録者90万人目指して
ますチャンネル登録よろしくです8月31
日は6時間バンカラ生配信スペシャル
ゲストも来ますみんな見に来てね
[拍手]
お母さん何してんの
先生って呼びなさい今回の林間学校は私が
印刷します
[拍手]
はいみんな集まったわねそれじゃあ電車代
の1000円しますお
待ちください
[音楽]
私も行こうかしらね
公共交通機関を使うのは時間の無駄なので
最短最安コースで向かいますみんな
快適な空の旅だったかしら
どこにあったよ
[音楽]
たまには植物がたくさんあって食料の豊富
なのあこの
草は食べられる草ねほら食べてみなさい
いただきます
全ての植物が食べられるわけではない自然
の脅威を身をもって体感してもらいました
それじゃ食後のデザートにしようかしら
ちょんちょんちょんちょんダメだって
大丈夫よほら
甘くておいしいちゅうちゅう
落ち着いて動かないで動かないで気になっ
たと思えば大丈夫だから
私に任せなさい
虫除けスプレー
一件落着です
[音楽]
バーベキュー始めるわよお
肉忘れちゃったー
それじゃあ人狩り行きますか
緊急時に自分で食料調達するそれも現代に
必要なスキルなのです
[音楽]
鉄砲持ってる
もん何だって思ってる
[音楽]
恐竜
頑張ってね
この
草よく燃えるのよね見ときなさい
燃えろよ燃えろよ
いただきまーす
どれが誰の肉か決めてなかったからね
じゃあこれ俺のこれ私の
おいふざけんなよ
逆に教職の世界です何
度も味が薄いわねそんな時は
胡椒で味付け
[音楽]
握手
あれみんなどこ行ったのあれ
ここが今日みんなが泊まる宿です
それじゃあ女子が先にお風呂だから男子
たちは休憩しなさいはーい
よいしょ分かってるよな
覗きに行くぞ
[音楽]
ここから見えそうだぞどれどれ
来た来た来た来た
あんたたち何見てんの
俺らみたいなおばさんじゃないんだよ
ほんじりどこだ
あれここにも昆虫いないぞどこにいるんだ
よ
[音楽]
おかしくなっちゃったみたい
お楽しみので
[拍手]
息抜きした人には
素敵なお菓子がもらいます優しい私は生徒
の電車代でお菓子を買っていました
[音楽]
気のせいでしょ
泥棒
これで終わりだ
おい今確実に口から出しただろう体から外
に出るのはうんこ以外ありえません
馬鹿じゃないの
ねさっきうんこって言ったでしょそこに
UNOが入ってるのよ
[音楽]
ちなみに今日は
ずる賢く生きる方法は
意外と誰も教えてくれないものです
[拍手]
もう寝る時間だからみんな早く寝なさいよ
[音楽]
[拍手]
早く寝なさいって言ったでしょう
[音楽]
[拍手]
私のお菓子は
あの子たち
何してもう
逃さないわよお菓子を返して勘弁しなさい
嫌なこった勝手なことって
お前
[音楽]
それはバーベキューの時に先生が教えて
くれた
植物だよ
なんだかキャンプファイヤーみたいだね
成長した子どもたちを見れて私は幸せです
[音楽]
チャンネル登録よろしく
またね